okay so this is the five nights at
Freddy's musical set it's still here
how long have you kept this up for why
you could have taken two down put it
back up it's like leaving the Christmas
tree up for a year straight I've already
done this with cabin sparkles the double
vlog you can't do it it says you can't
pull it off whatever blogging louder me
walk me a me do we're trying to figure
out pizza situation and it's not going
well
and now everyone's suddenly looking at
me because I'm vlogging which everyone
is looking at me anyway just vlogging do
mind me cash vlog beast as they go
around
hey how's that Cashman you look very
cash I mean I'll be honest ooh nice cash
soda singing going on there
I don't know about you but when I'm
filming YouTube videos at two o'clock in
the morning about killing animatronic
robots I drink diet coke please give us
money please these fan girls out there
hi so yeah it's been really busy this
week what you just saw was us filming
for the five nights at Freddy's musical
with random encounters and Nate wants to
battle and also matpat from the game
theorist you saw him there this is not
sponsored by diet coke they would never
sponsor us so we've been incredibly busy
with that if you remember last week I
put out a video called markiplier
catches a pen in his mouth which is the
epitome of entertainment that we have on
this channel but that's a whole nother
story but that was filmed in the first
session that we were doing for the five
nights at Freddy's musical with those
guys that was that Nate wants to battles
played he's a really cool guy thank you
so much for letting me use your bed that
sounds weird but you'll see what it
means it in the video hood it finally
comes out so that compounded with the
Warcraft in real life
capture the flag thing we were doing
with like 30 other youtubers it was a
huge bash I mean I mentioned it in a
video that what I was doing before but
it's just nuts the amount of stuff that
has been crammed into this week and that
doesn't even count the work that we've
been doing on the show Matt Ryan and I
I've mentioned this before will work of
working on a show and the script is
basically done we've just been doing
final reviews before we submit it and
also I've been working on a project with
Jack and Danny and we've just been
starting on that and that's an even
bigger project than the one I'm working
on with Matt and Ryan so it's all kind
of culminated on this week and the most
amazing thing is that throughout all
this craziness and all of the late
nights and all of the extreme amounts of
coffee almost lethal doses of caffeine
that I've been imbibing I've been having
fun like an unbelievable amount of fun
like an incredible amount of motivating
fun it's the time of my life because
I've always said this to you guys and
I've always encouraged you guys to try
to find this fire that motivates you to
move forward it's this fire that burns
in your heart and it burns so bright
that you want to wake up and immediately
start working on it and then you don't
want to fall asleep because you still
have more work to do like that
motivating fire is burning again in my
heart and that's a
amazing like it's so cool god that
cliche I need to stop saying that but
it's cool in that it motivates me to
move forward and it motivates me to be
more creative quote unquote catch a pen
in my mouth it's like let's ignore that
but it's like it motivates me to move
forward and work on these big projects
and it makes me so excited to be able to
do these things for you guys and to be
able to do these things period because
of you guys so that's why I actively
encourage you guys to pursue your
creative side so much because there's so
much untapped potential that you have
yet to see you're chipping away at the
artist inside of you and you just need
to keep digging until you see the whole
picture of what you can do and I'm
trying to be like you know less than
inspirational here but what what I'm
just trying to get across to you guys is
there is potential in all of us and I've
said it many times before but know that
I do believe that in every single one of
you there is a creative person or a non
creative person or a very logical person
depending on how you are and how you
look at the universe but there's that
person inside of you that you can craft
into the person that you want to become
and no one is gonna hand it to you no
one's going to give it to you you have
to work at that yourself
whether it's an artist under there or an
engineer under there or inventor under
there or whatever is under there you
craft that into the person that you want
to be and it's these moments when you
have this fire burning in you and you
have the inspiration driving you that
make you into that person quicker I know
that I tend to get overly excited about
these things but that's just because I'm
very passionate about this idea that the
idea that you guys have so much
potential in you because in me like I
know for a fact that I'm not incredibly
talented the only thing that I do is
ramble like an idiot in front of a
camera but I get so much joy out of this
gift that you guys have given me like
the gift of this YouTube channel like
the gift of the opportunity to
an idiot in front of a camera theat the
opportunity to do these amazing amazing
things with amazing people I just want
to get the words out ah just know that
in each and every one of you I firmly
believe that there is the potential to
do something amazing and it just takes
time to find that burning drive that
moves you forward so I think that
summarizes everything I'm not on a
presenter but I'm pretty sure that's
everything that I wanted to say so thank
you everybody so much for watching I
will let you know when these projects
finally come out in time it's very close
I keep tantalizingly teasing it but it
is close and it is amazing and I'm so
grateful for the opportunity to be able
to do it so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye